and we told you uh this i think uh
this whole week about the real
terrorists they're leftists using
intimidation and even violence and
violent campaigns now to threaten anyone
with whom they disagree politically now
we see this in their continued attacks
on pregnancy centers or the
assassination attempt of a sitting
supreme court justice but recent history
is it's no concern to the democrats take
congresswoman jackie speier
here she was today recounting her
harrowing encounter during the jonestown
massacre nearly 45 years ago
i believe i'm the only
member of this house that is a victim of
gun
violence my body is riddled with bullets
i live with that every single day
her ordeal was horrific but she breathes
right past something that happened less
than five years ago
it was then on a virginia baseball
diamond where a deranged bernie sanders
supporter fired off more than 60 rounds
at speyer's republican colleagues
five people were hit including my next
guest who almost died as a result
congressman steve scalise joins me now
congressman
now aspire's omission
on the day that these hearings are being
held
uh
it was a little bit convenient i can't
imagine she forgot what happened uh five
years ago your reaction
look i mean
clearly we all know what happened they
you know
whatever her reason was i think most
americans are just sick and tired of the
politicization
that you're seeing by the democrats to
try to change the subject they know what
american people are angry about american
people are angry about what joe biden
and nancy pelosi and their far left
socialist agenda have done to people and
they wish congress was addressing those
things not this hollywood production not
an attempt to take away your guns
it just seems like over and over again
they think they can blame putin they can
blame anybody else the american people
are smarter than that they figured out
who's the cause of the pain their
families and our families are suffering
and they want a change of direction as
speaker gingrich just talked about you
know what's coming in november is
something they're scared to death of
because they only want power they still
want to shut down cities they still want
to defund the police they still want to
do the things that the american people
are tired of and the american people are
going to have the final say on november
8th now when you watch this hearing
tonight and the you know the attempted
production value we're going to get into
some of that with raymond arroyo coming
up
but i don't know how much all this cost
but they've been working on this you
know for 18 months
i mean approximately
this can't be cheap and last time i
checked we're kind of broke
just to go over to grand central station
you'll see i don't know 30 40 people
living on the streets you know crawling
on the streets you know throwing up you
know on themselves because they're so
sick or addled with drugs i don't know
which but you know america is just
crumbling in urban especially in the
urban areas and yet we're just blowing
money on this for what reason
yeah and laura you know one important
question that we've asked the mainstream
media to ask speaker pelosi who paid
this hollywood producer because it's
against the law to use taxpayer funds to
produce a documentary trying to promote
their political agenda or go after their
political opponents and we haven't
really heard an answer you know who paid
this guy we know who he is not only
produced this video he also supposedly
covered up for jeffrey epstein you know
so he's got his own track record but how
did he get paid because
he's not allowed to get taxpayer money
to get paid and if you did it for free
that's an in-kind contribution which is
also illegal so i think the question of
who did pay him and how much did he get
paid and how did that transaction even
occur is an interesting question because
there may be violations of law yeah you
would think that it's the the actions
themselves on january 6 were dramatic
enough you didn't really need to bring
someone in to produce the drama i mean
right it doesn't make any sense
congressman great to see you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else